yo what up reject nation it's Greg Alba
here John so we're gonna watch today a
music video from Eminem from his latest
album here it's the song he did with Ed
Sheeran called River I've heard this
song a few times I actually do like this
song some one of my favorite Eminem
songs but I do like this song yes and
castles and walk on water doesn't
probably my favorite choices here but
here we go those music videos is
definitely longer than the actual song
oh yeah it heads up a lot of channels
that do music video reactions can only
feature certain parts of it you know
it's because of how YouTube's copyright
stuff works full lady's music video
reactions are all over on our patreon as
long as full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is a whole bunch of stuff so
if you want to see full leg music video
reactions more than just this one go
check out our patreon and patron of the
day shout out today for totally jumbled
because he reminds me of Eminem more
than any other patron
whether he
[Music]
eggs eggs cuz she loves danger like a
pen lately says minutes you'll be my
queen Stacy despite a man
[Music]
[Music]
I'm that guy in the music video right
we're choice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
damn that's that's great that's really
great
[Music]
and they recorded a lot of iPhone in the
situation that's right the song is he's
[Music]
[Music]
damn it's like it's like a found footage
like a horror movie about relationships
so many questions that was just about
the nature of this video and if any of
this is real or if this is all
recreations or if it's kind of a
hodgepodge both like it seems like it
has very little I'd aesthetic and they
made a lot of choices about when to use
like phone footage versus when to use
stuff that looks like an old camcorder
versus stuff that looks like a modern
music video I like it though I pre like
it is it cool video yeah I think it's
really cool I mean I like the fact that
it kind of messes with your mind and
wondering like what's real what's not
it's not real obviously there's no way
they would have just recorded all this
[ __ ] iPhone footage and all that it's
just stuff to make it feel like it's
real and Eminem tends to do that with
his song as a storyteller I have a hard
time paying attention to the really
fully capturing all the lyrics while
watching a music video so it took me a
second to be like oh yeah that's right
this song's about she's cheating on her
guy with him that's right that argument
scene when it's that one shot and you
just see them in the mirror that must
have been improvise because that just
felt so authentic we're really watching
real fair fighting it out dialogue they
were using two men that sounded very
authentic yeah I'll give it to him for
this album cycle I mean the music videos
at least so far have been very gripping
I don't love this song alone but the
music video made me appreciate the song
that
much more I actually like that it cuts
back and forth between you know the
Trevor guy and then mmm and then the
girl it's like you're watching a
found-footage thing of like a more
realistic thing of cheaters away with a
bunch more hitting cameras everywhere
planted in your phones planted in hotel
rooms I like em and I'm storytelling
songs of like a piece of messed up
relationships I do I messed up because
normally his you know messed up
relationship songs are about him and the
other person and they're just really
toxic and whatever and it's still that
except a little bit of a different
scenario that she's cheating on someone
with him and now they're in this
pregnancy situation yeah visually I just
like all the aesthetic choices you know
it changes locations a lot it hops
around different points in time which we
got to see a little bit more of the
Trevor guy honestly why she cheating on
him necessarily against not a song
doesn't have time for that and yeah it's
um just one music video - yeah I want a
whole movie based on this right here
right now I mean a lot of people who are
in relationships with people who are
already taken pretty crazy how often
that occurs and to know those people too
so if any of my friends are doing that
who watched this video I hope you feel
inspired and that [ __ ] people it's
clearly not healthy clearly doesn't work
out in my app it's not a smart idea man
and in terms of like the modern-day
music video shots that I really did like
that shot where they're exploding room
the exploding yeah that's a great
metaphorical shot just look so cool the
way they like these where you can really
see each a little bit of shrapnel every
spark every drop of rain flying and Ed
Sheeran and the chorus here I think is
great I think ed Sheeran really helps
make this song what it is honestly I
feel like a lot of people rolled their
eyes really hard when they discovered
that Eminem was gonna collaborate with
him on this album and at least having
heard the song a few times now I think
it's one of the more natural sounding
like yeah it definitely brings it a pop
element ed Sheeran is huge yeah I don't
think it's actually that unnatural and
especially here I thought it worked just
fine
if I'm being honest whatever I've heard
this song I've always appreciated it you
know it's like Eminem going for that raw
realistic type of
you know toxic messed up relationship
approach is something we're kind of used
to with him I don't really feel the
impact when I would hear this song alone
like it's cool I get what he's going for
and I overall like it but when I see the
music video I feel like it really does
enhance a lot of what the song is going
for because of the footage that they use
and the imagery they have here it
complements it a lot I actually think it
elevates the song don't often feel like
a music video will elevate the song like
I like the walk on water music video I
still love the song alone as it is not
like oh this music video maybe you love
walk on water more yeah that's like I
like the music wheel but it doesn't
really change the song for me I still
love the song regardless here I like I
like the song but now I really like it
because of the music video I think
that's a great effect for the video I
feel you on that 100% actually I feel
like the images and the sounds kind of
come together to make the most potent
version of this song at least in my
experience with it I thought it was
actually really nicely handled here and
it seemed like the visual elements were
always supposed to be there ya know like
it seems like this really skies I feel
like it was made for the music video the
imagery and the the lyrics everything
just feels sort of intrinsically
centered around the same concept this
now feels a lot more complete to me
sometimes you know you'll see music
videos for songs obviously someone heard
the song what ideas do we have for this
I don't know but it feels like the song
was written in tune to make it this
video yeah it feels like it was meant to
happen well on the splitting it up into
chapters once I got used to the idea was
was more natural to school like as I saw
more now yeah well hey totally jumbled
shout out today we are actually filming
this on Valentine's Day it's not going
up on Valentine's Day and patreon it is
patreon I wanted to say to you buddy I
hope that you and your wife can have a
lovely day alone I know you just had a
kid I'm hoping that on Valentine's Day
you can get away from the baby get away
from the wife go with your other
mistress and just have a great time with
her be a lot like mmm have another baby
have another baby outside of the
marriage you
right now I mean looking at you man
you're loaded with money dude so you
should be able to afford another kid on
the side yeah and anything raise that
kid better and then have them fight in
the future and I make a song about it
make a song about the whole experience
and then you could be yeah TJ has that
grit just with like Star Wars in the
background that grit and he's got bars
you know I'm sure he could drop you know
pretty a pretty heavy mixtape on us or
something I mean what the looks you got
and the attitude and confidence you got
I say make love to your wife let her go
to sleep she's probably tired from
raising the kid and then go to your
mistress and have a great old time there
tonight happy Valentine balance
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell get
notified every time one of our videos is
up yeah check out our patreon full life
music video reactions over their TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is a lot of
exclusive stuff over there go check it
out and we're sorry for the jump scares
in the winchester no we're not